[Music]
has someone been honored above you at a
dinner party or in salutation or in
being called to in to give advice
now if these matters are good you ought
to be happy that he got them
but if evil be not distressed because
you did not get them
and bear in mind that if you do not act
the same way that others do
with a view to getting things which are
not under our control
you cannot be considered worthy to
receive an equal share with others
why how is it possible for a person who
does not want some man's door to have
equal shares with the man who does
for the man who does not do escort duty
with the man who does
for the man who does not praise with a
man who does
you will be unjust therefore and
insatiable if while refusing to pay the
price
for which such things are bought you
want to obtain them
for nothing well what is the price for
heads of lettuce an oval perhaps
if then somebody gives up his oval and
gets his heads of lettuce while you do
not give your oval and do not get them
do not imagine that you are worse off
than the man who gets his lettuce
for as he has his heads of lettuce so
you
have your oval which you have not given
away
now it is the same way also in life you
have not been invited to somebody's
dinner party
of course not for you didn't give the
host the price at which
he sells his dinner he sells it for
praise he
sells it for personal attention give him
the price then for which it is sold
if it is to your interest but if you
wish both not to give up the one and yet
to get
the other you are insatiable and a
simpleton
have you then nothing in place of the
dinner indeed you have
you have not had to praise the man you
did not want to praise
you have not had to put up with the
insolence of his door keepers
this long chapter number 25 gives us
some really valuable advice
for situations that we encounter quite
often
and before we look at the specific
examples that epictetus has let's talk
about the general idea
which is that somebody has been
preferred to us
or or honored more than us in some
things so it could be
the examples that he gives it could be
all sorts of
other things you know uh in the internet
world it could be you write a great blog
article but then you see somebody else's
blog article
being you know posted everywhere going
viral and you're like wait a second what
about my stuff over here
why does that person's stuff get you
know talked about so much but mine
doesn't
or you know we could think about uh
friends and you know the friend
invites this person but doesn't invite
this person and epictetus gives us some
really
useful advice the three examples that he
has here that he starts with
are being invited to a dinner party
being invited to eat with somebody right
salutation is how it's translated
meaning you know how we greet each other
how we engage with each other we might
say right do you
do you stop on the street and chat with
somebody or you say hey
nice day and then move on right and then
here's one that that really
tends to wrangle with us being called in
to give advice
literally being brought in you know para
uh
uh the the term parlaith and i
is sort of like grabbing on to somebody
and bringing them in the room and saying
hey we want to talk to you right
they do that to your friend or colleague
but they don't do that to you
and then you feel bad and you're like
wait a second what am i
don't i rate and so he says
here's how we can look at it there's a
few points to keep in mind
here's the first point if these matters
are good
then you ought to be happy that the
other person got it
you have a choice if these things really
are good if it's good to have other
people acknowledge you
and say hey i want to i want your advice
if it's good to have people want to hang
out with you and chat with you
if it's good to get invited to the
dinner party or to have
drinks after work or whatever to have
tea with somebody to have coffee
then you don't have to feel bad that you
didn't get it you can feel good for the
other person
who got it because it's a good thing not
all good things have to come to you
and he says if they're bad then don't be
distressed that you didn't get them
right um they're not actually bad from a
stoic perspective but you know maybe
maybe you you start getting some sour
grapes and you're like i didn't want
those anyway
what a drag what a waste of my time well
if that's the case
then you don't you don't have to feel
bad about it right they got it you
didn't get it
and then he goes on and he says um
[Music]
bear in mind here's the most important
thing if you don't act the same way that
other people do
with a view to getting things which are
not under our control
things that are under the control of
other people their choices
their thoughts their judgments their
feelings their desires and aversions
if you don't do that then you cannot be
considered
worthy to receive an equal share with
others
this is great advice that applies to
everybody from
children to you know angsty adolescence
to 20-somethings to people in their
their you know late stages of their
career or life
if you don't pay the price then you
don't get
what the other person who pays the price
does is what epictetus
is saying and it's not up to you to
decide what counts as the price
it's up to the market out there of other
people's affections
and judgments and opinions and it might
be a totally irrational market
in which case maybe you don't want to
enter that market right
so he goes on and he says
how is it possible for is with a dinner
party how is it possible for
a person who does not haunt some other
man's door who's not
showing up all the time and chit
chatting and hanging around right
who does uh to to
have equal shares with the man who does
look if you're if you're not going to
hang around and you're not going to make
contacts
and you're not going to engage in the
the you know
small talk then don't expect to have the
same
reward that the people who do and you
might say
hey but that's unfair people should
recognize
my value and i shouldn't have to do all
the chit chat
well that's kind of funny to say isn't
it we'll see why in just a minute
but hold on to that thought he goes on
and he talks about doing
escort duty if you're not going to hang
out with people right if you're not
going to go to the
the places that they want to go to then
how can you expect to have the same
share as the person who does
well my time is more valuable i need it
for reading or i need it
for you know practicing my craft they
should recognize that
again with the shoulds right you're
expecting the world to conform to your
own desires
and then he says the man who does not
praise with the man who does
now praise here could be praising
what really is the case it could be
reasonable
rational praise hey this person is is uh
you know benefiting the company or you
know straightening things out in in our
moral environment or whatever but a lot
of times praise is what we call
puffery right praise is what we call
kissing butt
praise is choosing to look at the good
things and to
engage in amplification about them and
to ignore the bad
parts right so if you're not going to do
that sort of thing how can you expect
the same
share with somebody else who does and
again the retort here is usually
yeah but there should be a reward for
honesty
well why do you think that's the case do
you have control
over other people's emotions and desires
and the whole economy of how these
things
fit in with each other you're the one to
decide how culture should work
isn't that a little bit strange so
epictetus says
if you expect these sorts of things if
you expect
to get better treatment without having
to pay the price
you're actually screwing up he says you
will be
unjust therefore and insatiable
you're not just making an error in
judgment
you are unjust you are unfair
your your people don't like it and they
respond negatively to you if you do this
and they are doing something that's
perfectly rational
because you are being unfair and
insatiable
if while refusing to pay the price for
which such things are bought
you want to obtain them for nothing
for free you want or or with some other
coin
it's sort of like walking into a
bookstore and saying
i want to buy this book and not only are
you
you know one one thing that people don't
like is you pay in pennies right
okay that's already kind of a pain for
the people up to work behind the counter
because they have to count all these
pennies there's a line behind them
but imagine you come in and you say i
want to buy this book
and they say all right that's going to
be in the lobe edition
20 something 99 right and you say well
i don't have any money to pay you with
but i will give you a poem
or i will give you some advice or
i'll wash some dishes for you or pick
whatever else you like can i do a little
dance for you a little performance art
and they'll say get the hell out of here
that's not how we sell things
well it's it's the same way with all of
the other things that we want to
purchase
if we want the thing you pay the price
and if you don't want to pay the price
then you've got a problem so he goes on
and he says
think about lettuce what is the the
price for heads of lettuce an oval
perhaps that's a little tiny coin right
well somebody gives up his oval and gets
his heads of lettuce
you don't give up your oval and do not
get them do you imagine you're worse off
than the person who gets his lettuce
no there's a trade-off you either keep
your little coin
or you get your heads of lettuce you
can't eat your coin
but you can buy other things with the
coin if you want to right or you can
look at it if you get some satisfaction
out of that
or you can eat your lettuce and you
better eat it soon because lettuce tends
to spoil
so he says you're not worse off than him
he has his heads of lettuce you have
your oval which you've not given away
epictetus goes on and says it's the same
way in life you've not been invited to
somebody's dinner party
well of course not you didn't pay the
price you didn't give the host the price
at which
he sells his dinner you didn't get
invited
out for drinks with your your co-workers
or colleagues
well maybe it's the fact that you don't
hang around and chit chat with them
and express some interest in their their
lives and you say well their lives are
boring and mundane or i'm shy or
something like that
doesn't matter if you didn't pay the
price you're not going out for drinks
or whatever else you want to talk about
you know this is a
common issue there's a lot of people who
feel a sense of entitlement that they're
you know they're giving us something by
just sharing their company with us
and we should be happy to have that
epictetus says no no no
you you have to pay the price you want
to ask somebody out on a date
well you better actually smile at them
you'd better actually seem like somebody
that they might want to go out with even
if you nest
aren't necessarily that right and
they'll figure it out if you're not
because you have to continue paying
prices if you show up to the dinner
party
and you paid the price of praise
originally and then you turn off the
spigot
your host is going to say i'm not
inviting him back
so he goes on and he says look he sells
it for praise he sells it for personal
attention
give him the price for which it's sold
if it's in your interest
if you want to go to the dinner party if
that's really what matters to you
then go ahead and you know kiss a little
butt
because that's what it takes to get
invited if if you know
let's say another thing if having a
client
requires that you email them three times
because they
they're a little bit absent-minded or
they've got a lot going on and you want
to have that client
well you got to email them three times
and if that really is too much of a
burden for you then don't have the
client and don't complain about it
because you're the one who gets to
choose it's up to you
whether or not you are going to pay the
price
so he says um if you wish both
not to give up the one and yet to get
get the other
not to pay the price and to get the
thing you're insatiable in a simpleton
do you have nothing in place of a dinner
sure you do
you have not had to praise the man you
did not want to praise if that's really
what matters to you
not having to tell people you know
things about themselves that
aren't strictly true if honesty matters
to you
well then don't praise people then you
know you're not going to get invited to
the
dinner party so he says you have not had
to put up with the insolence of his
doorkeepers there's also sort of a
little kicker thrown in there
there's always like annoyances that come
along with even getting the stuff that
you want
you got a schmooze so you get in the box
seat thing
for the game you know and you watch the
baseball game or you go to the greyhound
track or whatever it
else it is and there's you know all
sorts of buffet
uh items out there for you to eat and
free drinks and yet the people that
you're there with are going to talk all
sorts of bs
that you have to listen to and you're
like ah i don't really care for this
um you know somebody is going to be off
at the corner you know
smoking or doing something else that
maybe you don't like
or maybe you wish that you could smoke
right you can't smoke there we go on and
on and on
every one of these things involves
paying prices
and deciding whether we want to pay
these prices
whether we want to trade it off for
something else it's perfectly reasonable
to think ahead of time what are the
prices that i have to pay
and to realize you can't have it all
you have to decide where your resources
are going to go
what the will of nature is may be
learned from a consideration of the
points in which we do not differ from
one another
for example when some other person slave
boy breaks his drinking cup you are
instantly ready to say
that's one of the things which happened
rest assured then
that when your own drinking cup gets
broken you ought to behave in the same
way that you do when the other man's cup
is broken
apply now the same principle to the
matters of greater importance
some other person's child or wife has
died
no one but would say such is the fate of
man
yet when a man's own child dies
immediately the cry is alas
woe is me but we ought to remember how
we feel when we hear of the same
misfortune befalling others
here in chapter 26 epictetus
is introducing one of these sorts of
considerations
that reverses perspective he says you
know
put yourself in another person's place
and then look at your own
conduct look at your own decisions and
things might appear to you a little bit
different
because you do the same thing when you
are looking at somebody else's choices
decisions
attitudes so he goes on and he says what
is the will of nature
is or what what the the you know
intention the bulema
of nature is may be learned by
considering
the points in which we do not differ
from each other
the way in which we are really the same
so we get a lot of perspective by
looking at
other people as being like us
and then applying that to ourselves so
he says for example when some other
person's servant
breaks the drinking cup you're instantly
ready to say
oh well that's one of the things that
happens right so when you go to somebody
else's place
and you know you look at their yard and
their yard is all messed up you say oh
well you know it's a drought
not not that big of a deal they may be
all broken up over it we do this also
speaking of breakups with relationships
right
uh somebody you know has a big breakup
maybe a marriage breaks up or they've
been going out with somebody for a while
or it's their more most recent
infatuation
and they are just inconsolate they're
like oh this is terrible
i'm never gonna meet somebody like that
what am i gonna do and they're down in
the dumps
and we come along and say they're there
there's other fish in the sea and we
we have all these catchphrases right why
do we say that sort of thing
how come we don't sit down next to them
and go oh my god it is so bad
oh you're so so horrible you're never
gonna find anybody
unless we're sadists in which case we
might do that right
we don't do that because we don't feel
that way we think oh they're
blowing it out of proportion they're
they're not
having a a clear sense about what the
situation really holds it's better off
for them
that that this person is leaving them
behind so
he says rest assured when your own
drinking cup gets broken
you ought to behave in the same way that
you do when the other person's cup gets
broken
so when you go through a bad breakup you
ought to behave in the same way
in accordance with the advice that
you've been giving your friends or your
family members
when they're the one who got dumped we
don't do
that but we could that is something
that lies within within the scope of our
possibilities we could choose to do
things that way
if we wanted to be consistent if we
wanted to be rational
that is indeed what we would do so he
says apply now the same principle
to the matters of greater importance
it's very difficult to think of things
that are
more traumatic there are many things
that are very traumatic in a person's
life
but the loss of a child is is one that's
certainly
far up there suppose another person's
child or
wife has died no one would know what
one but would say such is the fate of
man you know we said well
these are the things that happen right
yet when a person's own child dies
immediately the cry is alas
woe is me and he says but we want to
remember how we feel when we hear of the
same misfortune befalling others
if we think that they can manage
if we're ready to provide a kind of
sense of perspective the world has not
ended
it hurts a lot but you're going to be
able to go on
we can give that same advice to
ourselves when we encounter
similar situations loss poverty
death you know disease all the things
that we
we find ourselves fearing social
disgrace breakup of a relationship
uh the loss of a job all these sorts of
matters we ought to try according to
epictetus
applying the same advice inculcating the
same
perspective the same way of looking at
things
as we do for other people we ought to
bring that to bear upon ourselves
and if we can do that not only are we
being rational
we're also going to find that it helps
us deal with those situations
just as a mark is not set up in order to
be missed
so neither does the nature of evil arise
in the universe
chapter 27 is a very short pithy
statement
exactly the sort of things that the
stoics called a
dogma something that you could sort of
memorize and have ready at hand when you
encounter difficult situations this one
has thrown a lot of people for a loop
it runs just as a mark is not set up in
order to be missed
you know so a target you were shooting
arrows at a target
it's not set up in order for us to miss
it
neither does the nature of evil arise in
the universe
um you know the greek is
uh uda kaku fusis
uh that's the nature of evil uh and
cosmogenetic right it doesn't arise
it doesn't uh develop now what does this
really mean there's not
a lot to say about this this is
something we can use to console
ourselves to say
things are not set up in such a way as
to make them
necessarily go bad the universe is not
there
you know looking for an opportunity to
you know kick you in the teeth
when you're down that's not the way
things are actually set up
in fact for the most part things go
along pretty well
don't they uh you know if you can always
find something to to be upset about or
complain about if your desires
are large and have to do with outside
things but for the most part
we have a lot of things in our control
we we can decide how we want to approach
matters
we can decide whether we want to work on
our personality
on the structure of our desires and
aversions
choices rejections viewpoints on things
all of that is within our control and so
it's actually a pretty good place to
be this universe things are not set up
just to screw with us it is not some
sort of
plot the way the paranoid person thinks
to to persecute them
in fact we are being offered this this
golden opportunity to take what we have
and work upon it and to in fact be happy
so that's there's a lot more to be said
about this because this has drawn a lot
of commentary
down the ages in part because of the
somewhat enigmatic
framing of the sentence but i think
that's a good way to interpret it
as you're going through this this work
as a whole
if someone handed over your body to any
person who met you you would be vexed
but that you hand over your mind to any
person that comes along
so that if he reviles you it is
disturbed and troubled
are you not ashamed of that
here in chapter 28 epictetus is making a
very valuable
comparison that can allow us to put
things
into perspective and he talks about
somebody handing over our body
to any person who met us if you know if
it has to do with our physical space
and it has to do not just with our body
but also our possessions
or the online presence or other external
matters
we're ready to go on the attack when we
feel like
our rights have been violated that
somebody has betrayed us
that somebody has violated an agreement
anything along those lines so if if
somebody were to
do the extra step of turning us over to
somebody else's power we would be
understandably
and justifiedly upset about that
now why don't we feel that way
as epictetus points out when it's our
mind or
in greek literally it's attained gnomane
not the entire mind but you might think
of this as our faculty of
deciding of judging of thinking
things through why aren't we so upset
when somebody
hands this over or rather there's nobody
else handing it over it's
ourselves who hand that over to
somebody else and we might do this out
of inattention
we might do this because of bad mental
habits
we might do this because we're swayed by
various emotions
and desires and aversions we have
certain prejudices
we think ourselves totally free of
prejudices which is often in many
persons cases a deep-seated prejudice
itself
all these are things that can prep us
for not realizing that we are
handing over our mental faculties to
somebody else putting them in somebody
else's power
and we do that because we ourselves have
power over that
we can't make the decision to hand over
our faculty of deciding
and so he says
that you hand over your mind to any
person that comes along
doesn't that bother you aren't you
ashamed of that
and what does he mean by that notice the
example so that if this person reviles
you if this person says bad things to
you
if this person you know scowls at you or
talks to you in an unpleasant tone or
is impatient with you or doesn't want to
see you today right is brushing you off
you can get the sense
why are you so upset we become disturbed
and troubled he says we don't have to do
that
we have control over that if we decide
to take that control that's a big if
right there
if we don't do that then we're in effect
giving everybody else willy-nilly
our own mind to do with whatever they
they want
and many other people out there in the
world say i
don't want your mind you know do
whatever you're gonna do
but there are many other people out
there who are on the lookout for that
uh con artists um advertisers
advertising as a whole works by getting
us to buy into it
people who want us to vote a certain way
who want
our assent to certain things or want us
to reject certain things
on the internet those who want us to
click on the click bait and then share
it because we're upset or because
we think it's cute or all sorts of other
things as well
so epictetus is saying you know if the
reasoning
works for your body you don't want other
people to hand your body over to
somebody else then the reasoning works
just as well
for your mind except that it's you
that's doing the handing over
you